well the makeovers continue today and
we're honoring a grandmother
and construction site manager from los
angeles california cheryl bates let's
meet her
my name is sheryl bates and i'm from los
angeles california i have two sons and i
have four grandkids that i love so much
i assist the rehabilitation of
distressed properties throughout south
central los angeles and just change the
whole neighborhood if you see me out in
the field you may not recognize me
because i have a hard hat still toe
boots i've been on ladders i've carried
doors the job has to get done and i'm
not afraid i'm a conservative dresser i
have several suits my father always said
that a woman should always have a good
suit my friends say loosen up a little
bit show a little more cleavage have
something off the shoulder okay so maybe
they're right
i could use some help coming up with new
ideas new colors something different
can you help me
oh
i have to say i am in love with cheryl
and her best friend of 30 years veronica
love is here to see her bff's
transformation
hello veronica right here
well my goodness you're like a beauty
style maven yourself thank you thank you
yeah so do you only like hot fashion
people hang together is that the deal
you and your bestie well
not really you know cheryl is very
conservative i've always tried to get
her to switch it up some
i have not seen her with anything but
that blonde hair i can't even remember
her hair wearing
dark hair so i'm just so glad that she
had this opportunity in hopes that this
makeover will
transition her into adding more
style into her life
we have a drew crew extraordinaire
member
brandes daniel and she is literally
one of my favorite people she has a
company called harlem fashion row and
brandis is working her magic right now
and i'm telling you i would put myself
in her hands and i just love her and
trust her and i can't wait to see what
she does by the end of the show
the big reveal as we go to break let's
check out cheryl and see how she's doing
hey things are going great up here so
cheryl and i were just talking and one
of the tips that i was just giving her
is that so often we only think about
what we're wearing in terms of the
clothing but accessories that is where
it's at okay so
these cheryl i'm not gonna tell you that
these are what we might be wearing today
but accessories literally complete a
look and they are just as important as
the clothing or the outfit that you're
wearing the other tip is so often we
think in order to be sexy you know we
need to show a little cleavage or we
think that we need you know an
off-the-shoulder top but sometimes you
can just wear a really amazing maxi
dress with a slit and you look just as
sexy
so cheryl i hope you're ready i'm ready
i'm ready
drew crew member brandes daniel is
transforming our beautiful woman cheryl
and i am so anxious to see the final
look i really am well i have to say i
think that cheryl has the most beautiful
eyes so i can't wait to see them in
person come on out cheryl
oh
[Applause]
um cheryl oh wow
oh you see it
she
right
here look she is feeling it so you see
we changed the hair right the hair looks
serious amazing
and then you know cheryl said that she
likes conservative style she wants to be
conservative so we didn't want to take
her too far out of her comfort zone
however we did give her this slit to
show off those legs
and so what we did was we layered her
look so she came out with the blazer on
and then she has this is actually a
two-piece so she has on this two-piece
which is a part of the charles harbison
banana republic collaboration
and then we also wanted to give her she
said she doesn't wear high heels anymore
right cheryl right so what we did was we
gave her a booty which is just a low
flat heel that is a great way to just
take like your regular shoes like to
step it up a bit and it's quite
comfortable yes and then with her face
what we wanted to do was just add more
volume to her lashes and a pop of color
on her lips and her eyes and she just
looks stunning
how do you feel
well i want to cry
okay
i feel beautiful i feel
excited i feel different
because everything is different
and so i'm excited
and i'm just
honored and
every feeling that you can possibly
think about it that's how i feel right
now
thank you thank you
thank you
i think that you look so stunning thank
you she looks absolutely
how about your stylish best friend what
do you think
she looks beautiful
beautiful
[Applause]
it's one of my favorite uh instagram
sites and it just shows all of
brandeis's beautiful work and what she
does with designers cheryl bates and
veronica love i love your friendship
thank you for letting us be a part of
that and everybody thank you for
choosing to spend your time with us we
make the show for you
[Music]